we have Team coverage for you tonight
from the weather center in the airport
let's begin with Sasha Loftus out in
Reed International and Sasha has an
update there from the airport
[Music]
Ron as you mentioned that weather
luckily not affecting us here in Las
Vegas but it is affecting a lot of
flights coming into Reed International
take a look at the arrivals board here
earlier I counted 25 different
cancellations that's just keep in mind
over the last few hours and all coming
from the Eastern side of the country a
few from the Denver area a few if you
even from Portland but the majority were
from Baltimore we're from Philadelphia
areas like that so if you know of
anybody coming into the airport from
that area just be aware also a lot more
crowded than we normally see this time
of night a lot of people coming into
town that have made their flights but
again just an issue here if you are
flying or know someone flying to that
side of the country this storm really
affecting flights coming into Reed
International let's go ahead and send it
back into studio with chief
meteorologist Ted florendo for more on
that storm system Brian will stop